depuis les changements des horaires de
bus le 12 novembre dernier difficile de
s'y retrouver les usagers sont un peu
perdus par exemple cette dame a un bus
qui a été supprimé maintenant le
prochain il a 45 avant j'avais celui de
15 si je ratais celui de 04 j'avais
celui de 15 là maintenant je suis obligé
d'attendre jusqu'à midi moin le quart et
c'est l'heure où ma petite fille sort
pour trouver une solution au retard à
répétition et en finir définitivement
avec la greffe des conducteurs qui
n'arrivaient pas à IR les cadences fil
bleu avait donc repensé dans ses bureaux
les horaires de bus pour la direction la
majorité des problèmes est aujourd'hui
résolu les indicateurs sont au verts la
ponctualité s'améliore la régularité
s'améliore également il est évident que
nous avons encore des marche de progrès
il faut encore écouter nos clients et
mettre en œuvre des améliorations dans
le lancement de ce réseau les clients
justement ont-ils vu la différence
depuis la semaine dernière les bus
sont-ils à l'heure les avis sont plutôt
par partagé ça rien changé du tout c'est
pareil là aujourd'hui ils sont à l'heure
voire même une minute ou deux en avance
parfois donc ouais c'est plus agréable
ouais ça a changé que bah il y a plus
autant de Bu qu'avant il y a beaucoup
d'arrêts qui sont plus desservis comme
avant j'ai pas vu de changement pour moi
encore malgré des clients plutôt
mécontents concernant la qualité des
transports urbains le nouveau réseau
attire de jour en jour plus de monde
depuis l'inauguration du tramou en
septembre dernier la fréquentation
abondit de 90000 voyages par jour à 117
soit une augmentation de tr%